Герої для одних, злочинці для інших.
Навряд чи ще якась група настільки поляризує суспільство,
як Pussy Riot. DW зустрілася з ними в одній московській квартирі.
- Pussy Riot - це такий художньо-політичний колектив,
в якому немає конкретної кількості учасників,
а є люди, які беруть участь у різних акціях,
об'єднуються для їхнього втілення, і ось так існуємо.
Акції на кшталт цього протесту під час фіналу Чемпіонату світу з футболу
на московському стадіоні "Лужники".
Так вони хотіли висловити свій протест проти поліцейського насилля.
Гру довелося перервати.
Активісти в поліцейських уніформах прорвалися на арену.
Їх схопили і засудили до 15 діб ув'язнення.
- Багато людей не одразу розуміють, чим ми займаємося.
Їм необхідні додаткові пояснення. І ми їх завжди надаємо.
- Це нормально, що деякі люди не розуміють нашого художнього посилу.
Але політичний посил зрозумілий. І це важливо.
Коли Ольга Пахтусова стала учасницею Pussy Riot,
вона втратила роботу баркіпера.
Вероніка Нікульшина - модель, хоче стати акторкою.
Петро Верзілов працює для незалежної веб-сторінки.
Усіх їх хвилює відсутність свіжого вітру в російській політиці.
Звісно, багатьом це не подобається.
- Ми прекрасно знаємо, що багатьом людям не подобається те, що ми робимо.
Ми цілком до цього готові.
- У контексті моєї модельної діяльності
з'явилася одразу купа статей у жовтій пресі
про те, що я займаюся не модельною діяльністю, а проституцією.
Звісно, це не має жодного впливу на мене, бо я знаю, що роблю,
і я рада, що це роблю. І це важливо.
Вони усвідомлюють, що поліція стежить за ними.
І не чекають, що російські ЗМІ об'єктивно про них повідомлятимуть.
- Вони нападають на нас, тому що їм потрібно на нас нападати,
тому що ми Pussy Riot, тому що ми робимо не те, що їм потрібно,
бо вони державні медіа, які так чи інакше нападатимуть на опозицію.
Але настрою їм це не псує. Pussy Riot буде й надалі залишатися більмом на оці Кремля.